Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Cuphead. So we've gotten a couple bosses.
We are slowing down in our pace, but I'm not gonna let that get to me because I- uh.
*Mark reading the character bubble* "Ack that Wolfgang"
"Always taking ten notes to express two notes worth of music! He has no conception of what I mean by more-
-less is more! I know you agree with me. Go convince that tenured clock! He won't listen to me anymore!"
Alright, whatever. I don't know what you're talking about. "Rugged Ridge"
I'll get to whatever he was talking about later, because I right now have to take care of Rugged Ridge.
Alright, you know what- ooh- I don't like that. Well then, that boomerang thing ain't gonna- noo hey! (Mark, go easy damnit.)
Alrighty, then this is cute. Oh, hey come on now. Not fair. Not fair! Not fair! (I told you to go easy.)
Not fair!
Not fair. Man, half of me getting hit is just
me not knowing what to expect.
Well god damn it! You get- you- you and your aim!
Whoa- oh- hey- whoa! Way a big guy! Big guy! Big guy! Big guy! We got big guy here. Come on now how about this? (O_o Thats a big fellow right there.)
Oh yeah, that did the number on him. Who else is here? Nope. (Oh, you got him. Nice.)
Doesn't giving- whoa? How do you... how are you supposed to get that one? How- ah?
Ahh, it ain't worth it. I don't need the money that badly. I'm probably gonna die anyway.
Uh oh, why- whoa- whoa- whoa- whoa- whoa! Slappa. (JEEZUS CHRIST-)
All right, oh wow! (-slowly claps-)
Well I wasn't even close! I wasn't even close. This one's gonna be a tough one. Okay here we go.
Full HP and ready to go down the elevator of doom. You're a biggin'. Your a biggin'.
Why are you biggin'? Don't be a biggin' be a smallin'.
No, those dragons ain't gonna even get a chance.
Uh, I already killed your parents. I guess... (Damn, thats harsh.)
Whatever you want to call your... dragon buddy. Okay, you're dead. Like I just spun into a world, and it like instantly, whoop!
Welp, bye guys- woah! That's- that's peculiar. I don't like the look of that.
Man, I love this gun so much. Precision is key indeed. Nice discus throw. (True enough.)
No, why aren't they affected by the lion roar? Seems pretty stupid huh?
You know, I'm a switch. Cuz I have a funny feeling that I'm gonna be boned over by some stupid anytime soon now.
Oh, man, my trigger finger. It's getting hurt.
My trigger finger is really triggered here.
No, no, none of that. None of that. None of that. No, none of that. Yeah, that's right. Oh no-
I was a wall, and then I lived up for nothing though you're a thing and hey I don't like the look of you.
okay, well this is this precarious.
I really don't ohh I REALLY don't like this now. Well. You got the sassiest walk
I wish I could look at it, but god damn you are one
Saaassy piece of poop, ain't ya? You're lucky I got precision jumping skills because I am just
Absolutely shredding this obstacle course here. Oh gah!
I had to talk I had to open my big flapping flapper gums and
Goof around with me being stupid. Why did I do that? Why did I dash into nothingness when I was perfectly okay?
where I was?
Alright, whatever I made it. Oh you died ah you fell and died
Everyone's sad except they're not so just die
ahh
Okay alright, we got these results pretty good that took way longer than it should have
But that's alright and we did absolutely terribly, but you know what grade D - C! I'll take it. That's average
I'll take it
Consistency is the real deal in this endeavor. a boing a da boing a da boing a da ah look. I made stairs
I'm so happy about the stairs that I made,  what do we got here? Who's gonna be a dick to me, huh?
Alright let's see what's going on. I'll see how it goes and then I'll judge what weapons I need oh
Don't like this guy already
Don't like him already all right whoa whoa whoa?
Whoa whoa, buddy, buddy, buddy, buddy, buddy buddy there was no need for slap aah
You hate that?
And slappa okay
Yeesh, okay and slide whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
Oh shit that was right in front of my face. I don't know why that took so long
shoo ba da whoo ba da whoop
Monk oh no, I punched whoops Wow I didn't even see that thing
I don't know how I didn't see that thing, but I didn't see that thing. That's crazy whoa
Whoa I
Didn't I don't know why I ran into that that was not that was not what I was supposed to be doing hang on
Well, I got this I got this guys if I have a choice. I'm gonna take out the top laser
Cuz it just makes it easier for me because this is the this pure slap of energy
And that's oh why did I run into that though?
Impatience twitchiness there you can blame whatever you want. That's what that was all about all right. You're gonna go down, buddy
You have no choice in the matter
Haha got your head go. Hey whoa hey whoa whoa whoa?
Whoa whoa?
There really is no need
sir sir sir sir sir
sir Sir, sir
Oh, no, your heart your poor heart. Oh done
Whoa that I didn't realize that thing had such an explosive radius. Oh
Whoa hey, where'd dad go that's no good
You can't get me I'm too fast for you. You can get me
Oh wait, Oh, what's this Serbs it dub see that was no good man. Those guys are dead ah
Knock you out of sky you douche
Ball dogs so shocked out damn. I am oh oh oh boy. Hell. I'm slapper whoa. I didn't see that
Why did not see that big wall? I didn't see that big wall happening alright
Whatever whatever you think you can get me the answer is no ha ha ha
Ha ha ha slapper. Also wasn't paying attention to how much slappa energy. I was withholding
Oh no
Your whole operation got Tucker fucked well, what is that? What is that? What is that? What is that? What is that?
That's not right that doesn't seem right don't do that. Don't do that. Don't do that come on
Don't do that ok here. We go here. We go oh
God I forgot that thing. Why how did I forget that? I just saw that oh?
Whoops that was my bad. That was my bad. That was totally my fault
God but I only got one hit left side. I don't think there's gonna go very well for me yeah there
He is there is Ben. Oh god damn it
Why does this guy have it out for me by the way? He seems like a perfectly Noble scientist yet?
He's still he's making such a concerted effort to try to beat the shit out of me
And I don't take much too kindly to that oh he mad oh, oh god damn
You god damn you damn you damn you sir, Oh oh no no no no no, I forgot
I almost forgot about that okay, all right, and I'm gonna get him watch this watch this watch this watch this watch this boom
Baby, oh you thought you had me the answer is I had you naive this guy is not joking around here there
He goes though. Okay, all right doing pretty good doing pretty all right?
fancy slaps
Shit well God is so hard to see with all the shit in my way. Oh shit. Well. I've really boned this one up
Okay, here we go gun Avigail. Oh whoops well totally wasted that one every every chance
I had a victory has just gone out the window oh
Whoa whoa, I was not paying attention. I did pretty good there. Okay. He's not so bad
He's not so bad once you get to know him. He's really not so bad the bullet hell part at the end
There is probably the easiest face in my opinion when again no one cares about my opinion, so what does it matter? Oh?
Why forgot that guy shot energy beams out of those whoa I Y blanked?
Completely on now and those that was so bad of me. That was the worst thing I've ever done
Alright, let's see. Let's see let's see let's see let's see let's see let's see let's see let's see what you lap
Let's see what you got buddy come on. Do you think it better than me?
Huh what time to prove it buddy here comes the bomb. Oh can't dodge that bitch. Whoa. I'm too close
I'm too close. I got way too close for comfort there yeap slap
Whoa okay that was an almost bad maneuver
Why are you laughing so much your precious diamond is just exploding all the value off of it
Yes, he wasn't so bad once you really got to know him
Yeah, you get to know him intimately because apparently it lost his clothes right at the end there
But not so bad now the hardest one. I've ever had
Yeah, the bullet-hell part is easy like just getting to that part. It's just the hard part. That's all it is to it
Oh, yeah, me plus. Okay. Move it
Get out of my face
I love bolt hills by the way bull Adele's are my fav my jam I can do bullet. Hells all day
What is that for a second doctor cows robot? Well is it the robot soul?
That's that's collected because that's not so bad then so Ludvig has been feeling your mugs with his lesson Morris really
Keep talking to that fool and soon nothing will sound all right to you
Do you see I didn't burn you all right? Whatever you say man
What do we got here dramatic fanatic all right Phil the Fiat ah I'm down for a little theater
Whatever you say
oh
god, it's so weird going from like not doing the not using the
the
Ship oh. That's weird
Hey, what is your objective here? Oh?
Laughs here, art. Oh shit god damn it. What do you do?
Ricky you frigging Dancy pants here
Stop dancing and stop dodging my shots
Whoa ah shit? Ah man. I'm just not ready for it. Oh I see oh
boy
Okay, that's not good. That's not good is oh boy. That's not good something Bad's gonna happen. Oh
Shit I'm not gonna be able to hit her with this am I
Baby why do you have a baby oh?
Wow slap myself right into death there. Okay. Stay away from center stage. Let me try the other weapon
I don't think this. I don't think the charge one's gonna be best for this. That's right
Are we all having so much fun err I bet I'm not
Okay, where do you how do you away?
That's my big question here of all the things and polarities that I see around here
That might be the weirdest okay bye see ya. Have a good day. It's best to safety curtain
Oh boy breathe deeply what about me talking about me. What about being all right?
Well whatever you say these aren't oh? Whoa whoa okay? All right? Well. That's new oh boy
All right, I don't know if I'm gonna be able to hear ya, but good luck to you
to survive this oh boy, ah oh
Shit, yeah, I went right into that oh boy Wow okay, it's getting dicey. Oh shit. God damn it
I keep oh I keep forgetting that she can throw her fan. Oh
God, I thought she was going back saves ah shit. That was my bad those my bad for being a fool
today
Okay, that's what you see that you see the curtain pieces going up
That's the only time when she actually goes, so I don't need to be early about it
I just need to be less stupid about it
Which is a problem for me because I I have a tendency to be extremely stupid about everything that I do
Me what me what me what what are you talking about me?
Bah-bah-bah-bah bah-bah-bah-bah bah-bah-bah-bah, oh no you're mice. I want to slap of that Oh again. I slap it myself right into damage
So stupid so stupid so stupid to me. Oh these frickin mice. Why do you have mice?
Whoa whoa, there's a why the bottle the bottle
There's a world where you go to the the mouse drop placement to help you out
I think that's what you got to do. Okay. Okay? Okay, okay? All right lady lady lady lady
I don't like being there. Okay. Good. Good thing. I got that invisibility dodge like really that
Invincible dodge has made this so much easier. I don't even oh hey
I think didn't it like reduce my damage a little bit, but even so it's it's so worth it. Okay here. We go second phrase
Shit God again not paying attention to anything I'm doing oh the fan on the ground
Baby, baby
Alright come on you bitch come on you bitch come on you bitch come on bitch come on you bitch come on come on come
On and I'm just I'm not saying to try to be sexist by anything. I'm just like that's my go-to
Adjective to describe people don't read anything into that
Bitch yeah, bitch
Okay, here we go here. We go here. We go here. We go here. We go here. We go here
We go here
We go is the one there's one. There's one there boink who's gonna be the one I'm not gonna not gonna try to
Not gonna try oh god. I did I did the exact thing. I said I was gonna try to
Do but so skewed the damn you and your rat's
sack of shit, oh
Oh, oh you thought that you could know how to avoid me. Well the answer is Oh?
Your husband so sad
Putting whoa hey, whoa whoa that's weird meteor. What does that mean? I don't know there's a big wave. What is what?
Good thing I got this wow this is super weird lightning. Okay, all right Wow
Okay, all right. Well. You know I'd do a lightning again. Well. You know yeah, they say about lightning striking twice the same nice yes
I think I can walk under you can I yeah? I totally can yeah?
oh
God damn okay. Oh that's nice
Mario bro Oh No okay all right final phase
I don't know if I'm gonna make it. I only got one life left one hit left and I'm
Guaranteed I'm not gonna whoo oh
I don't like this. What are you doing Rose? Oh the roses are deadly? Okay? That's oh?
Shit Oh
Baby oh getrekt
erecting the hacking back Oh
Baby boom baby. Okay, all right that is all the time. I got for this episode. Thank you everybody so much for watching
I love this game so much. It's so fun
It is ludicrously fun, and I'm getting better at it, so I'm not great yet, but I'm getting better at it
So thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you think down the comments below and as always I will see you in the next video